[Musik]
herzlich willkommen am ersten
weihnachtstag wir beginnen die sendung
mit einer rede die längst tradition ist
denn jedes jahr am 25
dezember hält der bundespräsident eine
weihnachtsansprache in diesem jahr meint
frank walter steinmeier in der korona
krise zusammenzuhalten denn zitat wir
wollen auch nach der pandemie noch
miteinander leben über die großen themen
der ansprache david gehabt die
flutkatastrophe im sommer der
überstürzten abzug aus afghanistan die
bilder von europas grenzen im osten der
bundespräsident erinnert an ein bewegtes
jahr mit schatten und licht wenn wir auf
dieses jahr zurückschauen sehen wir
vieles da sonst kummer bereitet vieles
auch was uns angst gemacht hat zugleich
war da vieles in diesem jahr was uns
hoffnung macht ich denke an die riesige
solidarität mit den flutopfern an
spenden und vor allem ganz viel
tatkräftige hilfe der kern der ansprache
dreht sich um das gesellschaftliche
miteinander in der nicht enden wollenden
corona pandemie steinmeier ruft zum
impfen auf zur solidarität
der staat kann sich nicht für uns die
schutzmaske aufsetzen er kann sich auch
nicht für uns impfen lassen nein es
kommt auf uns an auf jeden einzelnen
sein dank geht an die große oft stille
mehrheit die verantwortungsvoll handeln
an ärzte pflege und ordnungskräfte doch
es gibt auch die unzufriedenen teils
protestierenden die sich abwenden nach
zwei jahren macht sich frust breit
gereiztheit entfremdung und leider auch
offene aggression
es stimmt in der demokratie müssen wir
nicht alle einer meinung sein aber
bitte denken wir daran wir sind ein land
wir müssen uns auch nach der pandemie
noch in die augen schauen können über
die bedeutung von freiheit vertrauen und
verantwortung werden wir uns immer
wieder neu verständigen müssen mahnt der
bundespräsident der im kommenden jahr
zur wiederwahl steht
und die gesamte weihnachtsansprache von
bundespräsident steinmeier können sie
bei uns direkt nach dieser heute sendung
sehen
auch während der feiertage wird weiter
gegen korona geimpft wie hier im
baden-württembergischen lauffen am
neckar nach dem weihnachtsgottesdienst
zum pigs gegen das virus
bundesweit wurden gestern laut
robert-koch-institut rund 67.000 dosen
verabreicht die meisten davon waren
booster impfungen
schauen wir auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen das rkw registrierte 22 1214
neuinfektionen binnen eines tages das
sind 20.000 599 weniger als vor einer
woche die sieben tage incident sinkt auf
242,9 an den feiertagen weniger getestet
und übermittelt wird könnten fälle
nachgemeldet werden
gerade in der korona krise hat pabst
franziskus zu einer größeren
dialogbereitschaft aufgerufen in seiner
weihnachtsansprache kritisierte er zudem
das wegsehen angesichts der vielen
krisen und konflikte auf der welt sie
scheinen nie zu enden und wir nehmen sie
kaum noch wahr so der papst andreas
postel aus rom besonders in den zeiten
der pandemie ein zeichen der hoffnung
auf dem petersplatz in rom der noch vor
einem jahr wegen der kroner maßnahmen
menschenleer bleiben musste haben sich
die gläubigen trotz regenwetters
versammelt von der mittelloggia des
petersdoms spendet papst franziskus den
feierlichen papst segen urbi et orbi der
stadt und dem erdkreis
eine richtige juni
potentat ich es
wie sand am meer in seiner
weihnachtsbotschaft ruf der pontifex zum
dialog auf zur konfliktlösung denn
während wir weihnachten feierten so
partsch franziskus gebe es viele
konflikte krisen und widersprüche an die
sich die welt gewöhnt habe die korona
krise so partsch franziskus verschärfe
die probleme im großen wie im kleinen
unsere fähigkeit zu sozialen beziehungen
wird auf eine harte probe gestellt es
gibt eine wachsende tendenz dazu sich zu
verschließen alles allein machen zu
wollen man verzichtet darauf hinaus zu
gehen sich zu begegnen und miteinander
die aufgaben zu erledigen
bereits in der christmette am heiligen
abend die diesmal wieder mit deutlich
mehr gläubigen im petersdom gefeiert
wurde forderte der 85 jährige
argentinier die menschen auf nicht nur
nach erfolg zu streben sondern mehr
demut zu zeigen
in seiner weihnachtsbotschaft hat der
papst doch dazu aufgerufen das leid
flüchten da nicht zu vergessen in den
vergangenen tagen sind in der ägäis
mindestens 30 menschen bei
schiffsunglücken ertrunken allein vor
der griechischen insel paros starben 16
flüchtlinge nachdem ihr segelboot
gekentert war die küstenwache brachte
die geretteten in den hafen insgesamt
wird noch nach dutzenden vermissten
gesucht
in deutschland hat die bundesregierung
ein neues gesetzliches modell für
lebensgemeinschaften angekündigt es geht
um die möglichkeit jenseits der ehe
rechtlich abgesichert verantwortung
füreinander zu übernehmen so
justizminister buschmann zb zwei
alleinerziehende die kein paar sind sich
aber gegenseitig unterstützen sie sollen
quasi als wahlverwandtschaft anerkannt
werden können was dann auswirkung hätte
zb beim mietrecht
so tief ins universum schauen wie nie
zuvor das soll das neue weltraumteleskop
der superlative james webb mehr als 30
jahre hat die entwicklung gedauert und
über 10 milliarden us dollar gekostet
heute endlich der perfekte start vom
weltraumbahnhof kourou in
französisch-guyana brachte eine
ariane-5-rakete das teleskop auf seinen
weg auch die riskante abkopplung von der
trägerrakete verlief reibungslos in
einem halben jahr soll das teleskop die
ersten bilder schicken und so einblicke
in die früheste zeit des universums
gewähren erst dann hat es seine
endgültige position erreicht und sich
vollkommen entfaltet
zurück zur erde so wird das wetter im
norden sonnig um minus 7 bis 0 grad
frostig kalt im süden ist es bis 0 bis
10 grad deutlich wärmer und es bleibt
trüb dazu kann es leicht regnen im osten
bayerns auch schneien die aussichten die
neue woche wird auch im norden deutlich
wärmer und regnerisch
die nächste heute sendung können sie um
22.50 sehen das heute team wünsche ihnen
noch einen schönen feiertag auf
wiedersehen bis morgen um 7
[Musik]